oh i got the 600 last night you got what
600 dollars from what
oh you know they sent us the stimulus
check who did
oh you already got it yeah trump or you
got it yeah i mean what happened to the
two grand well here's the thing
we're going back we're going back so
we're going to vote again all right so
if the it
passed to 2000 we get 1400. i'm
surprised you all didn't get this damn
you already got
they wired it they got that [ __ ] set up
ready to go have you gotten the stimulus
checked before
yeah i got mine before wait did you get
the first one yeah i got the first one
okay but the second one did you get that
one no i didn't get a second one no now
uh here's the thing and this is where i
got to get off topic for a little bit
bear with me while i elaborate
um six you say a lot you did it right
wait wait wait i feel like you threw an
extra m
you like elaborate
let me go through my elaboration all
right
here's the thing man a stupendous
goddamn
okay cool right so you got six hundred
dollars six hundred dollars nothing for
anybody
i know it doesn't matter now this is
where my complaint is okay so you know
how the u.s treasury we gotta go and
borrow money and we have these hearings
to vote for
american middle class to get two
thousand dollars which everyone's in
debt
right we're not working and you gotta
use all these credit cards to get food
and stuff like that now i just work for
xbox
right and everyone we all play pay
income tax in here yeah right they taxes
exactly in california so they took a tax
i got my check
xbox took the income tax took half of
that
right i'm not gonna say that i'm not
gonna say what they took but took half
of that
and you explained you're saying between
your your federal taxes and your state
taxes
you should not half but us you should
have prices 40 percent
let's say and they obviously got paid
more but say they paid you a thousand
dollars you probably got six hundred
dollars
exactly yes but you see how easy it is
for them to take out my
money yeah right i'll hold taxes exactly
yeah yeah i hope they're taking
that money that we spend and give to the
government for these other people
they're like you know that's like
putting food on these tables like how
hard it is to get two thousand dollars
for the middle class america they have
to vote
that's the problem like yeah i feel way
better about get paying these high
california taxes
if i knew what they were going to do
exactly
black white asian whatever if you if you
giving the money to people in need
i don't have any problems me too yeah
but the fact that but if you have no
idea what they do with your money i
don't know that's the problem
look look look at how free we're taking
look at like well like just like the
poor like
look at have you been on the 101 lately
there's like yeah there's like one part
of the 101 where it's just like a
[ __ ] community
of like just homeless homeless after 101
yes where not your area 101 my area
he got real hold on
don't be hating on the 101.
you go right it gets a little dicey
hey it's so funny because that's true
but look at this look at me the 101 but
look at uh the west side
like you know chin just moved to the
west side i told it was when i first
moved here
everybody wanted to be on the west side
the west side was the [ __ ] spot
yeah and now everyone's like jesus
christ because the homeless
because newsom and these laws that they
pass they push all the homeless to the
west side
so if you go down wilshire like
brentwood where it's like the most
expensive
real estate in all the land dude it's a
[ __ ] camp of homeless people
really i mean dude tent city so how just
yeah how is that allowed bro this is the
laws that they pass like yeah
they're the police can't do much they
can't push them out now because the laws
yeah but they're they're taking
you know two thousand dollars it's hard
to give the middle class working
american people
and we've been in this pandemic for a
minute but that's all i had to elaborate
i'm sorry because i said
i'm mad as hell xbox collaboration
elaboration education yeah how about
that when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son